what about 1 billion subscribers you've
uh passed PewDiePie's the most
subscribed to YouTube channel uh when do
you think you get a billion uh let me do
some math real quick so we're on 120
what do you think about this no I don't
honestly I because one thing you'll find
if you want to gain subscribers if you
want to get views if you want to make
money and almost any metric in this uh
video creation space if you want
something it all comes back to okay well
then just make great videos so instead
of like focusing on all these arbitrary
vanity metrics I just kind of focus on
the one thing that gets me all that
which is make good videos but and that I
do think we will when they hit a billion
subscribers I don't have a plan on going
anywhere even though we're only on 120
million right now on the main Channel I
think like we're doing around 10 million
a month now and
um YouTube Just yeah I just don't see it
going anywhere and I I don't see any
reason why I'd ever get burnt out or
quit so I think with enough time yes I
wanted to ask you those family friendly
questions before I go to the dark
questions so now we have dark questions
right now but if you wanted to hook them
you would start off with the dark
questions that's how you get them